he's Frank Martin a South Carolina head
coach the Continental Tire Coach's
Corner
coach good to have you with us again
good to see him thanks that great to be
here with you guys what did you think
the forum you're sure here's your dogs
mine yours is good yeah
Doug's dogs interesting but it all you
you don't want to have somebody on your
tomb as an interesting shot no but if
they're gonna have an interesting shot
they'd better lead the league in assists
and that's what he used to do but if you
had have you ever had a kid who had the
yips like Doug said that you get out
there and you go to the free-throw line
and people always say well come on it's
15 feet away nobody's guarding you but
you're all alone when you do it guys
would rather have two guys draped on him
I think than shoot free-throws yeah you
know then anytime I go speak and there's
always the one guy in the in the
audience that says coach do you like
ever practice free throws because I used
to make 95 out of 100 and I say yeah you
know my old age if you let me stand
there and just kind of shoot like free
free mind yes anyone can make them but
the game is played under duress at all
times you're constantly moving there's a
guy in your face you're trying to shoot
it you barely see the rim when you shoot
it then all sudden they stop the game
and you got to go to the line and
everyone's standing there in the stands
the cameras and everyone's looking at
you if your mind isn't clear
that's a hard moment and that's the guys
that have the yips that's usually what
happens we used to practice this in high
school where we would shoot free-throws
and then we would run full court
Sprint's and then you would stop and
then if you you know depending on how
many if you made both free throws
then it was X number of laps and and if
you made both it was X so you there was
pressure applied to it and it was you
were tired when you got to the line
there's a lot of people shoot
free-throws it's like you know you're
not winded but if you're playing in a
real game you could have gotten knocked
down get up you got to go to lion games
on the line but you know there's there's
a psychology to it I think and I think a
lot of these guys get to the line and
start thinking more about it than they
really should and then you'll get this I
hate this excuse Oh his hands are too
big for
to shoot free-throws excuse me there's
something to that no there's no there's
none that try shoot a volleyball I can
oh come on not the same way you should
if you give me a if you give me a
volleyball that's the same weight as a
basketball I'll shoot 75 to 80% I get
that it's I'll say this
if you stand and shoot a women's
basketball which it's a little smaller
yeah in my hand you notice a difference
but eventually you get used to it yeah
so I don't know I've never really spent
a lot of time in that I what Shaq used
to say he'd say I make them when they
count you know it's uh but then again I
mean that ball looks like a tennis ball
in his hands that's got to be difficult
what happened you know do you look back
on what happened last year with its
incredible run and you know that you
were you were the media darling uh-huh
you see the way I'm dressed today you
got your gear on you're ready to go I
thought we had poison no you're doing
the DP so you're not running practice I
got confused but it was incredible you
know then I say this all the time like
the moment that everything hit me I'm on
the court they're playing the national
anthem and I felt like the tourist in
New York City walking down the street
looking up at the tall buildings and I
said Frank everyone's looking at the
court like relax so and I look straight
across the court like they teach you in
speech class when you're a little
nervous just kind of find the spot and
stare and I look across and I see Jim
Calhoun when I see Toby I see Eddie
Fogler now I get even more nervous I'm
saying these are the Hall of Famers and
I grew up watching they're here to watch
me coach or my team play whatever but
then the jump ball goes up and all that
goes out the window what would you tell
Loyola relax
treat this week the same way you would
treat it for a conference game
everything around you is telling you
it's different
enjoy it you I said this to the porter I
said Porter you might win a thousand
games in your career and never get the
opportunity to
through this week again it's it's not
too many people have this moment oh so
you talked to loyalist coach we we're
friends okay we visited and and my whole
thing was whatever your technique is to
prepare your guys to play a game like me
I'm a big two-day guy I love to have two
days to prepare for a game so like when
I tried to manage this week last year
for our players my whole thing was enjoy
it have the time of your life you've
earned the right for everything that
comes your way
when Thursday hits it's our two days
Thursday Friday play Saturday and I
tried you know just enjoy it let those
kids they've sacrificed so much to get
your team to this platform but at the
same time there's still two games to win
you know it's not time to celebrate yet
so the mindset has to be one that's
normal for me you have to be me I can't
be different I can't walk in and be
louder than I usually am I've got to be
the same Frank that I always am I can't
come in and now all of a sudden be
accepting accepting of mistakes or
high-fiving if that's not what I do on a
regular basis I have to be Who I am so
the kids stay in the same place so they
have the best chance to win
how does loyal to keep it's coach I
everyone thinks everything's about money
in life and some people make decisions
based on money money doesn't bring you
peace of mind doesn't bring you
happiness the people around you do and
and but sometimes you don't know that
until you you have to find it out on
your own yeah but Porter's been fired
before he understands you know he wasn't
fired from power five school but he's
been fired he understands what it is to
to go into a job and he was winning and
take this new job and all of a sudden
whatever happened I don't know I wasn't
there and people tell you hey you know
what what you're doing is not good
enough for us and and he's and he was
around one of the Great's in our
business and Rick Majerus one of the
great people that just comprehended
basketball and the business and so
Porter's ground that he understands and
he's not gonna make my decisions based
on money I hope to people Loyola he's a
Chicago guy if I'm not mistaken I'm
pretty sure he's a Chicago guy so he's
home he played high school in Chicago
yeah it's its home and I don't know it's
uh you know it's Brad Stevens was a
butler
obviously mark view of Gonzaga those
schools have made unbelievable
commitments to basketball
I know Lola's got history someone said
Lola's got no history they got history
yeah they've got history if they make
the commitment I can see Porter wanting
to be there be a part of that he's Frank
Martin South Carolina basketball coach
joining his Continental Tire Coach's
Corner yeah people would look at you and
I think we talked about it last year
that they thought you were this drill
sergeant this like this marine like the
haircut like you I think people are
surprised when they meet you they expect
you to be like this drill sergeant can
you imagine how boring life would be if
you're that grumpy just all the time
I mean it's you do look like you could
play the role coach listen you know Dan
if you get people thinking certain
things then they kind of like don't know
how to approach you that's just a little
better sometimes but now I'm just joking
about that but if I'm if you're mad at
me
right is it a look or do you say
something it's a look you might like
what's the look I'm not mad
well I get mad here's here's where it
comes from Dan my ears where it comes
from
um my grandmother who was the basically
the backbone of our home when I messed
up as a kid which is pretty often she
didn't have to say a word all she did
was look and I knew like okay stop or
she's taking the broomstick upside your
head pretty soon oh boy yeah and and so
that's where where that look comes from
and players know our players know when
I'm happy when I'm mad sometimes they
know that even though cuz I'm a
passionate guy when I'm competing they
know that even though I'm loud I'm not
mad you know and they know because we
live with each other and it's we confuse
people that are loud
with negativity and it's it's not like
that it's hard to leave it live in
negativity if you got in the Octagon
with the other SEC coaches who's winning
oh boy who who is the one who walks out
of the Octagon if all the SEC coaches
get in holy cow I'm keeping myself out
of this one no no you're in I'm in yeah
Oh like you're a one-seed I'm not I'm
not you're not throwing me over the top
ring rope Dan no no but who makes you
nervous if you were fighting with the
other SCC like Calipari is not he's not
making you nervous man no no oh no who
would make you nervous oh boy uh you got
me thinking here who's Bernard
Bruce Pearl yeah no not Bruce maybe
Avery cuz he's so small okay he's so you
know Avery and he's small and strong and
and you know big guys don't like to
fight small guys cuz they're hard to hit
and hard to grab and then when you do
grab them you want to go to the floor
and it's hard to tie them up and they
grab your arm and bend it the wrong way
and you got to tap out everyone says
look at that big dude tapping out
against that little guy but I don't know
I I'd bet on myself on that yeah yeah so
we're celebrating our 20th anniversary
army we didn't we put bret baier up and
hugs down around here bob bob we went
out with bob huggins one night and we
had beers didn't we at several of them I
I'd like to say this you and I would not
be having this conversation in this
frame of mind right were you my tag team
I think you were on my it was it was it
was us against them and hugs is a big
guy Brett Barrett played at Kentucky
he's about six eight six nine
yeah I'll say this they were Loyola
Marymount that night no no we were loyal
of Chicago nobody thought that we could
pull off the upset we did no doubt we
were going up against the valedictorian
he likes to tell you and Bob Huggins and
and the big blue and the Big Blue Nation
bret baier up and I knew I was in
trouble then when bear kind of did one
of those Irish bombs or whatever they
were called
car bombs a car bomb you know and it
kind of like no went down and back out
wiped his face and he says I'll have a
and you were a high school coach at the
time you know coach comes up to me goes
you know I met you with hugs a long time
ago and I'm thinking oh my gosh
I said how did I treat you and you said
treated you well you were great
yeah you were awesome yeah you were
great yeah and now I because I was
thinking I do I remember that and then I
realized why I didn't remember it
because we were never drinking it was
complicated and look at us I'm still in
the same job in your coach in South
Carolina hey let's let's be happy they
those cameraphone that's very good
I'd be in a lot of trouble right now by
the way I'll leave you with this how
close were you to getting Zion
Williamson oh I don't think I can so
you're not I don't think I can speak on
guys that that that are still out there
but he committed to do yet well until
they signed scholarship papers are okay
because I know I asked you last year and
I knew you couldn't can you just like
show by your fingers like how close you
were you think so no words here so
thanks tough and I'm not let's I'm not
speaking of other things the way your
legs are kind of angled you're you're
showing more than you need to know the
show my speaking of my nice car loose
ball drill down
there's a couple loose balls over there
he's Frank Martin South Carolina
basketball coach Continental Tire
coaches corner coach always great to see
you keep smiling
Thanks DP five Continental Tire Coaches
Corner many have gone through the
process of breaking in new athletic
shoes you want them to feel just right
you can perform at your peak so just
like shoes your tires need to be broken
in as well visit Continental Tire comm
for more details for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]